Welcome to your second drink of two weeks.
This is a fun episode.
You guys, we tried Scotch and Splenda in this episode.
I know.
Jenna, you brought it all in.
I don't want to ruin it for anyone who might be listening for the first time, but I reflect
very fondly on that.
Also, it was so early in the morning.
It was really early.
It was a little crazy.
We also talk about how much we wanted to interview Idris L before the podcast.
Yes, and we still do.
This reminded me that we need to still try.
and make that happen. I want us to put it on our manifest board. Well, the last time we checked in with him,
his people said he was on a set somewhere for five months. Yeah, I can't remember what that movie was.
He's very busy. He's very busy. But, you know, maybe when the five-month project ends address,
you would like to come into Office Lady's Studio. Yes. All right. Well, listen, I have a quick bit of
extra trivia for this episode. It was originally titled Two Weeks Notice. And then it got changed to two weeks.
Do you think that's because of the movie Two Weeks Notice? You know, the one with Hugh Grant and Sandra Bullock? Two Weeks Notice. Do you remember that rom-com?
I mean, I remember hearing of it. I did not see it. Have you seen it?
Yeah. I went through a Hugh Grant thing. I was like, he is the funniest person I've seen in a long time in movies. And what's crazy is I was just flying and I watched Notting Hill again.
I love Notting Hill.
Oh, stop it.
I mean, I've seen that movie so many times.
The bench.
All of it.
Well, anyway.
That dinner party is one of the best scenes.
I would love to be in that dinner party scene.
So good.
And yes, it's Hugh Grant.
It's two weeks notice.
It's like Hugh Grant is doing it.
It's just, you know, now.
Yeah.
You know what?
I feel like it was a decision here.
I am completely spitballing here, guys.
There could be zero truth to this.
Okay.
I feel like this is like something a network suit would say.
They'd be like, you can't name the episode two weeks notice,
because there's already a movie named that.
You know what?
I actually had a whole other, like, thing in my brain.
What was that?
Here's what I imagined.
I imagined a bunch of dudes in the writer's room calling it two weeks notice.
And then Mindy Kaling walking in, Mindy Kaling, like...
Loves a rom-com.
And she's like, what are you doing?
That's already a thing.
And I feel like she had to school everybody.
Okay.
This was my imagination.
I like both of these theories.
Okay.
All right.
Well, we also got this letter about a favorite moment from the episode.
is from Danny H in Duluth, Minnesota. Danny says,
Hi, office ladies. My favorite scene from this episode is actually a scene added back into the
Superfan episode. It's when Michael and Toby are in the break room.
Michael is asking Toby for advice on what to do with his life and what his resume should look
like. I did not expect to be so tickled by this scene, but towards the end when Michael
is speaking directly to the film crew as if he's saying some inspirational monologue in a movie,
and it just makes me wheeze. Please, please, please, touch you.
on this scene as it is a gem.
Well, we love this scene selection, Danny, and you know what?
I think we should share it.
I'm going to set it up for everyone.
Michael is coming to terms with the fact that he has put in his two weeks notice,
and he's kind of freaking out about that fact,
and he doesn't have a plan for the future,
and he goes back to the annex, and he's going to get advice from Toby, like you said.
Let's hear it.
Hey, Toby, I have a real quick question for you.
Sure.
What should your resume be and what should you do with your life?
Okay.
Two questions, I guess. Fine.
No, no. No. I'm thinking to what I said.
One question with two parts.
Okay, well, look, the second part, you know, that's really personal.
I mean, only you can answer that.
So you're trying to get out of it? God.
Thanks for your help, moron.
Okay, well, look, the resumes. I can really help you there.
I must read 20 a day.
Okay. Good. Write this down.
Born in a medium-sized town, Michael Gary Scott always knew he was different.
Okay, so we might start with, say, your most recent thing, summary of achievements.
What have you done here at Dunder Mifflin?
Changed things. Ushered in a new era of love and comedy in the workplace.
Hired many, fired few.
Made money, lost money, learned to stop counting.
This is our moment.
This is our time.
This next part should be sung if possible.
That's Michael's resume.
It's brilliant.
It is brilliant.
I don't know how Paul Lieberstein made it through that without laughing.
Because for me, the thing that always got me with Steve is how, as Michael, he would take these pauses.
Yes.
And then say something ridiculous.
He takes this time.
You don't know what's coming.
No.
Well, I really have to thank Danny for suggesting that we go back and watch that scene because it's really awesome.
And because of Danny's letter, I ended up watching the whole superfan version.
And I'd like to offer another scene that was added back.
It's between Michael and Daryl.
So after Michael realizes he's not going to get a job someplace else, he gets his idea to start his own paper company.
And he goes down to Daryl's office for advice on starting his own company.
When Michael needs something from Daryl, it's maybe one of my favorite dynamics.
It's like this superfan episode has a Michael,
Toby and it has a Michael Daryl. So I think we need to hear Michael and Daryl.
Hey, Double D.
What's up Mike?
Michael.
Oh, ooh.
Hey. You'll just excuse us for a second.
You know what? You could stay. Why don't we...
This is good. I just had a question. You guys work in a warehouse.
How much warehouse space do you think a paper company would need if it had like 25 clients?
Hoping someday to expand.
Maybe like a garage?
Would you start in your own company?
No.
Can I invest?
Yes.
Yeah.
My money's tied up.
I'll tap down.
Shoot!
Darn it.
It sounds like a sure thing.
Oh, doesn't it?
Mike, I'll answer all your questions, but I need you to know something.
I'm messing with you.
This doesn't sound like a good idea.
Understood.
Okay.
You want to start his own company, and I was just trying to disway to.
him. I tried. I honestly tried. So there you go. Michael, trying to get some advice on starting
his paper company. How much space does he need for all the paper? I like that Daryl really earnestly
tried to talk him out of it. I know. Oh, man. Well, this superfan also has a great runner of
talking heads of people giving their opinion on Michael leaving. They come after Hank leads Michael out of the
office and they watch him drive away. The broadcast version has a single Oscar talking head,
but in the superfan version, a lot more of us weigh in, and it was fun. Let's listen.
And just like that, as mysteriously as he arrived, he was gone.
I would like to say that I will miss him. I would like to say that.
I'll miss him when he dies. I'm not going to spend energy missing him every step of the way.
I'll miss Michael.
But have you seen this new guy?
When God closes the door, he opens a window.
You know what I mean?
Oh, Crete he outlives yet another boss.
Time to put a marble in the box.
So I guess Crete has a box on his desk, and it's filled with marbles for every boss he outlives or lasts.
That's so great.
There were like five marbles in there.
Oh, my gosh, that's really funny to me.
Well, Angela Martin also had a candy bag alt, which we shot, and it went like this.
I don't know what lies in Michael's future.
He's an able-bodied man with a formal education, so I'm sure he'll survive.
Truthfully, though, I wouldn't be surprised to find him begging outside of my church in a few years.
I can see him now with this little misspelled sign.
I love that his sign is misspelled in Angela's fantasy.
She's just such a bitch.
Oh, listen, bottom line, the superfan version of this one.
is really great. You get like whole extra scenes. There's also this great added Michael talking head,
but where he reveals he has a pet gecko. I highly recommend it. I saw people write in about the gecko.
A few people wanted to know if Michael had a gecko, what would he have named it? And I was like,
I don't know. All right, everyone, we hope you enjoy your second drink of two weeks.
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate ultimate.
Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give
exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the
office ladies. Oh, good. I always want to say good morning. I know you do because it's 9.30 a.m.
I know, and I'm having a cup of tea. I'm having a cup of coffee. Hi, guys. Today we are talking
about two weeks, which is Season 5, Episode 21, written by Aaron Shore and
and directed by Paul Lieberstein.
As we were warming up today here in the studio,
literally warming up because it was very cold.
Yeah, it's freezing in here.
And we were waiting for it to warm up.
We were talking about how much we love writer Aaron Scher.
Yes, Erin, you're delightful.
We are enjoying all your emails and just reconnecting with you.
And you have the best stories.
The best stories.
It's no wonder they use so many stories from his real life in episodes.
Here's a summary.
At the end of the last episode, Michael told David Wallace he was quitting.
And guess what? It's true. Yeah. He has given his official two weeks notice and he has also given up on doing any work.
Have you ever given a two weeks notice? I have. So have I. It's the most awkward two weeks when you're at your job but everyone knows you're quitting.
Yes. And it's true. You kind of coast. I mean, I didn't walk around with, you know,
know, Scotch and Splenda, but you kind of phone it in. Well, I gave two weeks notice at a job,
and in that two weeks, it was my job to hire my replacement and train them. So I had to conduct
interviews and put out a job posting and then create a handbook for my job for the next person.
You had to do more work. I did. I did more work in my two weeks than ever before.
I remember giving two weeks notice and then when I was finally done with the two weeks, I got in my car and guess what came on the radio?
What?
I'm free, free fall. And I was like, it's a sign.
Is that how you felt?
Yes. Like in a good way. Not a bad free fall, like a good free fall.
Yeah. You were done with that job. Sounds like you didn't like it.
I did not like it. And you know what? I was a little bit of Michael Scott during my two weeks.
Well, Michael is going to take a turn when he learns how bad the current job.
market is. He suddenly starts to panic and in the end he is going to start his own paper company
and he's going to start by trying to recruit Dunder Mifflin employees to work with him. But pretty much
everyone says no. Except Pam. Pam. Pam. Pam is the only employee who is going to join Michael
in his new adventure. The Michael Scott Paper Company. I love this runner. I do too. Fast fact number one,
When I was looking at the script for this episode, it aired on March 26th, 2009.
That was my sister's 30th birthday.
That same year, I turned 35, or five years apart.
And I remembered what we did for our birthdays to mark these milestone birthdays.
What?
All right.
This is a story where my family back home is like, I cannot believe this is your life.
And I always say, this is not my life.
This is a moment.
This is like a crazy thing that happened.
a club in Vegas.
I remember this.
This club in Vegas, and I am so sorry, I cannot remember your name.
Oh, no.
I'm so sorry.
Because I know so very little about clubbing in Vegas.
But this one time in my life, this club in Vegas reached out, and they said that they would fly out my friends, family, whoever, give us an all expense paid trip to Vegas, a dinner.
I remember this, Jenna.
because I had a little baby.
Yes.
And I couldn't go.
You couldn't go.
And then you're texting me from Vegas.
So I flew out my sister and her husband, and then I flew out Lee's brothers and sister.
So it was like all of the brothers and sisters-in-law met in Vegas, and we partied hard,
and it all kind of culminated in this club experience, which I'd never had before with bottle service, sparklers.
Sparklers and cupcakes.
with my picture on them.
Crazy, crazy.
I have to tell you.
So I wasn't able to go.
And then the next year, the same club.
Oh my gosh, club in Vegas.
We don't remember your name.
We were so sorry.
The same next year.
It was really fun.
We'll figure it out and we'll definitely tag you in a photo in our stories.
We'll figure it out.
The next year, same club.
Privy?
With like an accent on the E?
Yes.
Okay.
So the next year, the same club reached out to me and Mindy.
Because Mindy's June 24th and I'm June 25th.
And they said we will throw you a joint birthday party in Vegas, fly you out, the whole shebang.
And Mindy and I were like, oh, my gosh, remember Jenna talking about it?
We should do it?
Mindy, do you remember this?
I remember this.
And then whatever, we couldn't do it because we just had too many moving parts.
But there was a split second where Mindy and I were in hair and makeup and we're like,
should we go to Vegas for a birthday?
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
Privy.
Privy?
I think it's Privy.
Privy.
A delicious dinner, I have to say.
Well, dang.
Dang it. Casino Club area. It was pretty dang cool. That's a great flashback.
Moving along to fast fact number two, you mentioned Scotch and Splenda. Yeah.
Tastes like Splenda gets you drunk like scotch. Michael first mentioned this drink in season
three cocktails when he was having drinks at David Wallace's house. That episode was written by Paul Lieberstein. This episode is directed by Paul Lieberstein.
So Paul clearly loves his scotch and splendia.
I found a recipe for scotch and Splenda, and I thought we should have it today.
Shut up.
You're not.
Wait, I haven't had, I didn't have much of a breakfast.
Here's the scotch.
Oh my God, Jenna.
Wait, Sam, did you know about this?
Cassie?
Cassie's getting the ice.
Here's the splendor.
Cassie, did you guys know?
I didn't.
Okay.
And then I thought.
I've had one pancake for breakfast, only one.
I thought we could drink it out of our own.
office ladies, glasses.
I love these. Look.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, everybody.
You can have sprinkles.
I'll have the teapot.
Okay.
Sam and Cassie can have some Dundies.
This is me opening the Splenda.
Oh, my gosh.
All right.
You guys, it is 9.57 in the morning.
All right, so here's what you need.
You need one packet of Splenda.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
Two ounces of scotch.
and some ice.
I mean, I don't know what this is going to taste like.
We're going to be here for a bit.
All right.
I'm going to open the scotch.
It's really happening, guys.
I thought this would be fun.
Only Cassie knew because she had to get the ice.
I was like, do they have ice here?
Here we go.
That's ice going in.
Sturry, sturdy.
Okay.
Just so you guys know, this is what my parents think my job is.
No, don't say that.
I'm certain this is disgusting.
We're going to let you know.
Is everyone ready?
Wait, one second.
Drink responsibly.
Okay, ready?
Here we go.
Cheers.
Cheers, everyone.
Oh, my God, you guys, it's not bad.
I don't hate it.
Yeah.
Splenda.
I don't have anything snarky to say.
I don't hate it.
It's really nice.
I would totally drink this if you served it to me at a bar.
I am maybe going to ask for this the next time I go out.
This tastes like something Applebee's would have.
Okay, wait.
Jenna, if you ask for Scotch and Splenda at a bar, I hope it shuts down.
I go to Chili's and ask for Scotch and Splenda.
Yes.
Oh, my Lord.
All right, guys.
Cheers.
Cheers, everyone.
All right.
The chunking it.
Sam, bringing back the chunk.
Wow, it's really kind of good.
Michael Scott was on to something.
I truly believed it was going to be awful, and I like it.
I like it, too.
Sam thinks we should do a spinoff podcast called Scotch and Splenda.
I can't wait to see what we talk about on that podcast.
I know.
All right.
Fast fact number three.
Shortly after this episode aired, the NBC office website,
sent out a mass email to all subscribers from Michael Scott about the fact that he was quitting Dunder
Mifflin.
Yes.
And this is what it said.
It said, as the manager of Dunder Mifflin Scranton, I learned two things.
Everything about the paper business and that Dunder Mifflin is a sucky company.
I am taking that expertise and creating the Michael Scott paper company.
I cannot promise success, but I will promise you the best.
effing time of your life.
So anyone who was subscribed to the website got that email.
This is so in the vein.
I know it's going to come later, but when Jim's like, you know this is an industry on
decline.
And Michael's like, I practically invented the decline.
Like, this is the kind of energy he's going into his new business with.
Oh, well, listen, that's all I've got for Fast Facts.
A story about Vegas, a little scotch and Splenda, and a surly email from Michael.
It's one of my favorite fast facts we've ever done.
The Scotian Splenda might have had something to do with it.
Well, why don't we take a break and we'll come back and get into this episode.
Let's do it.
You guys, we are back.
Michael is holding court finally in the kitchen.
He has everyone's attention.
He's telling them the story of how he quit, how he went to New York and quit and told David Wallace,
I want you to know this is called the purple cold open.
in the Kinsey Chronicles of the office.
Why is it called the purple cold open?
I will tell you, Jenna.
Angela Martin is wearing a purple turtleneck and a purple cardigan.
Pam is wearing a purple top under her cardigan.
Kelly is wearing a purple striped button-down shirt.
Oscar has purple squares on his tie and sort of faint purple stripes on his shirt.
Stanley has purple stripes on his shirt and purple flowers on his tie.
And Kevin also has purple stripes.
I will have you know when I saw this cold open, I noted the numerous jewel tones, but I did not break it down like that, and I applaud you.
I just was like, what happened?
What was Alicia?
Like, where was her?
She was in sort of like a, I don't know, a spring awakening mode of her life.
Everyone had purple on in this whole kitchen scene, minus Michael.
Everyone else had purple on.
Hmm.
Just saying, I found it fascinating.
Now the episode is going to start.
Michael is walking around with one of those gooey, stretchy hands.
You know, your kids get them at a county fair.
And then they smack them on the window and that leaves the gooey residue.
Michael's walking around, smacking pieces of paper, yanking him back.
He messes with Phyllis's hair.
I remember Phyllis broke on that.
I do too.
That's why you see her from the back because she was laughing.
And I love how he tucked it back in his suit pocket and just the hand, like hung down sadly for the rest of the scene.
This is also when Michael is drinking his scotch and Splenda.
Yeah.
We reached out to writer Aaron Shore, the writer of this episode, because we were very curious, who wrote, Taste Like Splenda Gets You Drunk Like Scotch.
Yeah, we got to know.
I mean, it's just too good.
And he said that that line was created in a pre-table draft pitch session.
So what that means is the writers, they would kind of typically work together to make an outline of
each episode and then a specific writer, in this case, Aaron Scher, would go off and write the whole
episode based on that outline. And they usually got like about a week. Well, they would turn in their
draft. They would get notes. And then they would also have these pitch sessions. Right. They'll get
notes. Sometimes a few of the writers will be put in a pod to pitch on a certain element of the script.
Yes. And that is exactly what happened with Scotch and Splenda. A few writers got together and they said,
we want a really funny joke for this moment when Michael is walking around with a drink in his hand.
And Aaron had saved all of the pitches.
Stop it. Oh my gosh. All of the, oh my gosh. What were they?
Okay. So, Kevin says, is that scotch? Yeah.
And here are the various pitches that Michael would reply.
Yep, from a fire truck shaped bottle in my office.
or better southern comfort.
Or, nope, diet Pepsi and water and ice and scotch.
Or, it's non-alcoholic scotch.
And finally, the one they went with, Scotch and Splenda,
tastes like Splenda, gets you drunk like scotch.
And then that is the joke that they ultimately picked for our table read draft,
which is the draft that all the actors got and that we would read out loud.
I love it. My number two would have been a bottle shape like a fire truck. I liked bottle shaped like a fire truck as well.
Because I remember like my dad had like a novelty liqueur that I think it came in a stage coach. I don't know, but like it just sat on the shelf.
Well, the cool thing about those extra lines was then at the table draft, if a, oh, Angela is having a sip of scotch and splendor.
I see you here. Because I was like, well, we are talking about scotion, Splenda.
It wasn't a joke, folks.
We're really drinking it.
Sipping.
Sipping it.
We're really sipping it.
That's your, you are sipping.
But what I was going to say is the interesting thing is that those extra jokes, the ones they didn't put in the table draft, they would save in that candy bag document.
And then if a joke didn't land at the table read, they might go over there and replace it when it came time for the shooting draft.
Or they would have us do it on set all the different alternates.
Right.
Sometimes I think the writers just wanted to hear them just for fun. Even though they knew we weren't going to use any of them, they would hand you a page. And if we had time that day in our shooting schedule, we would just do a whole bunch of alts. And it was always so fun. So fun. Stanley thinks Michael should start looking for another job. Michael says he has a job, to which Andy points out for four more days.
Yeah, and he's like, you kind of got to get your act together here.
Well, Michael has a talking head where he is not worried.
I mean, what's he going to do?
He's going to do a little bit of this, a little bit of that, and he's going to stop worrying about calories.
So during this whole montage of, like, people giving Michael advice, there was a scene in the shooting draft that didn't make it.
And Kelly walks into his office and she's like, Michael, what are you going to do?
You know what I would do?
I'd move to Mexico.
I'd live on the beach.
I'd be naked.
I'd make jewelry, have amazing sex.
drink lots of margaritas. She just kind of goes off on this whole thing. And while Kelly is rambling
on and on about what she would do, he is carving into his desk. Michael was here. Oh my God.
And he really carved into the top of the desk. I was like, did we trash a desk for this like
scene that never even made it in? And I wasn't the only one that noticed. Olivia C wrote in and
said, in the deleted scenes, they're on the DVD box set guys. We see. We see.
that Michael has carved, Michael was here on the desk. Did Steve really carve that into the desk?
Olivia, I had the same question, but guess what? Randy Cordray had the answer. He said our production
designer Michael Gallenberg created a matching desktop out of the exact same similar wood. Wow. I know.
That was laminated over the actual desktop because we were shooting scenes out of order and they couldn't
have different stages of Michael carving into his desk in the episode because then it wouldn't match.
Yeah.
So they just had this laminar at top they would put on top and then they would take it away.
Now let me ask you this question.
Okay.
That means that Veda, our script supervisor, would have had a chart.
And on that chart for each scene, it would say carve desk, no carved desk.
She would have tracked when we should see the carving.
Yes.
But they didn't know they were going to cut this scene until later.
Right.
So is it possible that we can see this carving on his desk throughout the episode?
Maybe. You'd have to be close, right? Like over his shoulder. Yeah. But I mean, probably what a headache for Veda. It's like keeping track of all that. And then it didn't even make it in. I'll have you know, Angela, at 2 minutes, 48 seconds, we had a fan catch from Flora K. There is a blooming plant at reception.
Flora, good catch. I knew it would make your heart happy, Angela. I saw it too, Flora. You know, the last time we had a blooming plant at reception was,
beach games. So you think this is connected to Pam? Pam is going to have her moment here. She's going to have
another moment. She's going to bloom again today, like in beach games. Now, I know we talked to Steve
Douchererer, who told us that it was a coincidence, that it was a blooming plant for beach games,
but Steve Douchererer, again, with the blooming plant, Pam is blooming. I think it was subconscious.
This is that group mind thing. That's what I was going to say. This is creative group mind.
Well, Michael is now going to move into the kitchen. I guess he's hungry, so he's looking for some food.
He's a little tipsy, and he's going to go, like, raid the refrigerator. Who hasn't been there? Come on.
In the script, it just said that Michael takes out a container clearly labeled Phyllis. But you know how he's eating it? And then he's like,
Phyllis, none of that was in the script. Oh, really?
Nope. Steve just improvised that. Oh, that's so good. Andy comes in.
and he wants to give Michael some wine as a farewell gift.
It's actually a really nice gesture.
It is.
And Michael just doesn't give a crap.
Michael would love it if Jim came in and gave him a bottle of wine.
I know.
But, you know, it's Andy, so he's like, ugh, I already have wine.
This next scene I loved because Michael's sitting on the couch by front reception,
and a man walks in, he's interviewing for Michael's job.
Yeah, Michael is kind of on the couch,
reading a novel. I zoomed in on it. I tried to see what it was. It's like a woman in a martini
glass. It's clearly like a romance novel. No, it seems like one of those like books for women
about, you know, claim your space sort of book. Yeah, yeah, like a motivational. Yes, that's what
it looked like to me. I want you to know a couple of things. At four minutes, 16 seconds,
the blooming plant is on the move. It's been moved to the other side of the
reception desk. So you can see the couch better. Yep. The man who's interviewing for the job is named
Mr. Isaac Silvey, and Aaron sure told us that he was named after Aaron's kids, Isaac and Sylvie.
Isn't that so cute? Yes. He had originally named the character Mr. Engbritson, but Paul Lieberstein
told him, no, name him after your kids. So that's how he got the name Mr. Isaac Sylvie. He was
played by David Grant Wright, who has appeared in several episodes of Better Call Saul, Crazy Ex-Girlfriend
in Brooklyn Nine, and pretty much every soap opera you can imagine. David is an incredible actor,
and I read his bio, he is a 27-year cancer survivor. Oh, wow. He wrote a one-man show called
With Flying Colors about his cancer experience, which he has performed for the last 25 years,
raising thousands of dollars for cancer patients.
Good human alert.
Yes.
That's fantastic.
Well, in this scene, Michael finds out that Isaac has driven all the way from Philly.
Michael's like, gosh, that's a heck of a drive.
And Isaac said, yeah, well, this is one of the few places hiring.
It's rough out there.
And you sort of see the realization coming over Michael's face.
Jenna, there was more to the scene.
It was so good.
I read it in the shooting draft.
He has his resume.
Isaac. And Michael's like, can I see that? Michael is so blown away. He finds out that Isaac was the president
of the company he used to work at. Wow. Yeah. And now he's driving all the way from Philly for a
regional manager position. Michael is so blown away by his resume. He says, can I keep this? And then he
really starts to spiral and he goes to see Toby and ask Toby for resume advice. Like how to beef up his
resume. This made it into the deleted scenes. It's so good. Can we hear it?
Hey, Toby, I have a real quick question for you. It's about a resume. Sure. So we might start with,
so your most recent thing, you know, summary of achievements. What have you done here at Dunder Mifflin?
Regional manager, Dick Watt. Okay, that's your title. You know, how would you actually describe
what you did? Change things. Ushered in a new era of love and comedy.
in the workplace. Hired many, fired none, made money, lost money, learned to stop counting.
This is our moment. This is our time. This next part should be sung if possible.
That made me laugh so hard. The scene continued. Toby said, how would you describe what you did?
And Michael has this speech, and it didn't make it in. This is Michael talking about himself.
Michael Scott always had a strange recipe for success.
Two cups of spirit, a half a thing of inspiration, two spoonfuls of love, a water bottle of danger,
a pinch of praise, a dash of hopes, a sprinkle of cinnamon, two pats of butter, a box of cake mix,
and a little bit of cooking oil.
Preheat of it.
Wait, what am I describing?
That's his description of what he did.
Okay.
That talking head is very funny, but I have to say what?
I think I can tell you that's the scotch and Splenda.
Because it's so funny to me.
Is it not that funny?
No, but I've shared a drink with you before, Angela, and you're getting into that.
I'm tickled.
You're getting into that, yes, that territory where you giggle.
I haven't even had a full scotions blend.
No, no, you haven't.
And I just have to say one more time.
It's so good.
It's really good.
I know.
All right.
Let's move on.
Yes, let's.
We need to talk about this new copier.
I guess, you know, we have this whole runner about copier or chairs.
We never saw them get their chairs, but they have gotten a new copier now.
I did love that for the whole beginning of the episode, it was wrapped in like the blue sort of packaging, and no one said anything about it.
I just love how things are in the backdrop like that.
I do, too.
Pam has a talking head where she says that they deliver.
delivered this new copier, but they didn't set it up. So Pam's job today is setting up this
copier. This would do me in. I wouldn't be able to do it. I don't like reading instructions.
I don't like manuals. When I get any kind of appliance and it comes with the manual,
I just stashed the manual in a corner. This is reminding me of the document that we got when it was
time to do the layout edit of our book. You guys, it was like building a small Cessna. Are we
allowed to take a picture of that and put it on the pod because to me it looked like like some
sort of scientific formula. It was all of these instructions for how to make a comment on the PDF.
And when I looked at it, my brain exploded and you got on the phone with me and said,
I can't do it. Lady, I can't do it. I will mess it up. So we got on the phone together and
every time you had a note, I read the document and I carefully made the note on the PDF. So if you
buy our book, Office BFFs.
Just know that we now know how to, well, we, Jenna knows how to do a note on an elaborate
layout craziness document, and I learned how to build a Cessna airplane.
Yeah, but we cared and we put that love and care into our book.
I'm buzzed.
I know.
While Pam is going to be putting this copier together, Kevin is constantly bugging her.
And there's a lot of Pam sass here.
Yeah.
I loved shooting this scene with Brian.
We shot it first thing in the morning.
They would do this when there were scenes at reception in particular that didn't feature the rest of the office.
That meant nobody had to be in the background and you guys didn't have to come in so early.
So Brian and I came in first thing.
It was probably 637 in the morning when we shot this scene.
But I loved it.
We had so much fun and I got to sass him.
I think that we learned.
that in the accounting department, Kevin is tasked with all the menial tasks.
Like, go make photocopies. Go do this.
You're so right.
That's why he cares so much about the copier.
It's his one job.
When Pam talks about how a copier goes through a lot,
I loved the runner of things that happened to this copier.
Oh, yes, we didn't talk about that.
It's so great.
First of all, Creed puts coins into it.
So right there, Creed is like probably messed with all the mechanisms.
And Oscar's like, I think it's 75 cents.
So he keeps feeding coins into it.
And then, of course, Bandit chews on the wires.
And then Kevin dumps a whole cup of coffee over the entire copier.
It's no wonder this thing doesn't work.
I know.
I had a question for Randy Cordray at 5 minutes, 12 seconds.
When we see Bandit chewing on the copier cord, I was like, Randy, do we know who the
cat actor was?
Because you have this whole list of the cat actors.
It looked like Bandit.
Well, Bandit was played in this scene by the ever-reliable Milkman.
Oh, Milkman.
Randy said it took several days of training to get Milkman to actually chew on the cord,
which was painted with sardine oil.
Oh, wow.
The training of the cat, the labor, the transportation costs,
the cat rental for this episode, for this very simple three-second insert shot cost us
Any guesses, anyone?
Three seconds, a cat licking a cord.
Any guesses?
Cassie?
She guessed $2,000.
Sam?
I'm going to go big and say $10,000.
I'll hit it in the middle at $7,7,000.
$3,710.
Oh!
Cassie gets it.
Cassie wins.
Closest without going over.
And once again, we use Bob Dunn's Animal Rentals from Somar, California,
with Denise Sanders, our lead cat trainer.
Once again.
A simple little three-second joke.
It took somebody a week to make happen.
Yeah.
We are going to go to Jim's desk and over his shoulder we can hear monster sounds coming from Michael's office.
And I love this line when Jim says, it's monster.com, singular.
He knew. He knew.
We actually got a lot of mail about this bit.
Okay.
People wondered, where did we get the monster sounds?
Well, as it turns out, it was none other than our post-production supervisor's voice, Jake oust, making monster sounds.
Get out.
Yes, Jake!
I guess he just recorded monster sounds into a microphone.
And then our sound supervisor, Bobby Maxton, took the recording, added some reverb and some scary special effects.
And that is how we got our faky monsters.com website.
Jake, really good job with the monsters.
I agree.
This leads us into a Michael talking head where he says, if you work in paper long enough, you get to know the players,
and he's going to start calling some paper companies to maybe, you know, get a job.
Well, we find out there's only one on his list.
Are you ready for the saddest outgoing message ever?
Yeah.
Here it is.
I've had to inform you that after 40 years of serving the community, we are no longer in business.
Thank you for your support.
Yeah. Oh, that was harsh. That was Prince Family Paper, the small family-owned paper
that Michael and Dwight have clearly put out of business. The little girl at the end.
Bye. I'll have you know, they were uncredited, but we brought back the original cast members of
the Prince family to do the voices. That is Dan Desmond as Roger Prince,
And Emily Ray Argenti as his granddaughter, Rebecca Prince.
Like when I heard that again, I mean, I knew it was coming, right?
I knew it was coming.
But still, I was like, in his voice waivers, I was like, ooh.
I know.
Well, Michael needs to now figure something out.
So at 16 minutes, 49 seconds, he's going to start throwing stuff at Jim to get his attention so that Jim will come in his office.
Yeah, he could have just called Jim, but instead he's going to throw a kush ball at him.
Well, Jim goes in his office, and Mike.
Michael's like, close your eyes because I'm going to tell you something.
And Jim will not close his eyes.
And this is when Michael reveals he's going to start his own paper company.
Mm-hmm.
Leading to your favorite couplet that we talked about earlier.
Yeah.
Do you know how the industry is in decline?
Do I?
I practically invented decline.
He goes on to tell Jim he has a name for the company and he wants Jim maybe to be a part of it.
He's very excited.
It's a big no from Jim.
I'll have you know.
At six minutes, 44 seconds, I spotted something.
What?
The desk.
No.
Do you remember in season three, the job part one?
I noticed that the outlet in Michael's office, the one under the big photo on his sidewall,
was upside down.
Correct.
And in that podcast, we learned that you can install outlets any way you want,
and they still work.
Yeah.
You can put them sideways.
You can put them up and down.
Yeah.
I also said in that episode that I would be tracking outlets.
I'll have you know.
You didn't forget.
I didn't forget.
And if you look at that outlet, it is now facing up.
It is facing the correct way.
Tadda!
I kept my word.
Well, you did.
And the outlet is now up and down.
There you go.
Outlet tracker, Jenna Fisher.
Mission accomplished.
Charles is going to interrupt.
Jenna is taking a drink of her scotch and Splenda.
I've been drinking water.
Busted.
What?
Yeah, I just saw you drink.
Charles is going to come in.
And once again, Jim is in the wrong place at the wrong time.
And he breaks up their meeting.
Yeah, because he says, Michael has given his two weeks notice.
Jim, did you also give your two weeks notice?
And Jim's like, nope, nope, nope, I'm going to go have a seat.
We just need to find a way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay, okay.
So, I literally just said, I just want to say something.
We need to, I was going to say, we need to find a way to get to break.
But you said to get to drink.
That's what I said.
We need to find a way to get to drink.
You guys, I want you to know, it is 1048 a.m.
Maybe we should go to break and drink some water.
I think we should go to break and drink some water.
We'll be right back.
Okay, we are back.
We have hydrated ourselves and,
is eating some cheese.
Jenna, drink some water.
We're going to be very serious podcasters now.
We're serious.
Don't worry.
By the way, I wanted to start, before we jump back into the episode, I just want to give a big plug to B.J. Novak's new show on Hulu called The Premise.
It is so good.
I've seen every episode.
BJ, you are killing it.
Every episode is standalone.
It's like an anthology show with a different cast.
He's directed many of them.
He's written them.
You know what I didn't expect?
So I just saw the first one.
BJ starts it.
Yes, he has an introduction moment.
Yeah, and I was like, oh my God, BJ.
I didn't expect to see you.
Well, they're great.
BJ is one of the smartest people I know.
Him and Mindy are just...
Two of the smartest people in the room.
Yes, always.
And he has this way of articulating complex thoughts
in a really relatable way.
And brilliantly funny way.
Yeah.
He's the guy who wrote Diversity Day.
That's all you need to know.
He's also the guy that wrote the book with no
pictures. It's one of our kids' favorite books, and we've read it to them over and over the years.
The sort of scope of BJ's brilliance is really amazing. Yeah. BJ, we love you. We love your show.
Check it out, the premise on Hulu. And if you have a youngan, the book with no pictures,
you will love it. Back to the episode, Pam is on the ground with this copier manual.
And Dwight comes over. This is a really cool shot.
This was directed by Paul Lieberstein. This was his idea to put the camera on the floor with Pam.
I thought it was a really great idea. You know, at a certain point, there's only so many ways to shoot this documentary, and he found a new one.
I think Paul liked to have some of the artsy shots, because do you remember when Jan goes to comfort Michael and he's sitting in the train?
Yeah. You just saw the faraway shot of his feet. Yeah.
So I think Paul likes those interesting shots. In the next scene, Michael goes out.
Except Pam. Kind of sneaky. He wants her to help him make a order form for his new company.
Which is basically Dunder Mifflin's order form, but with Michael Scott Paper Company in the corner.
In place of Dunder Mifflin. Right. She's like, okay, all right, let me think about this. And she comes up with this way that they could kind of do this.
I can scan it. Yeah. And he says, I was thinking maybe we would just tape it. Put a little piece of paper over it.
tape it. She's like, okay. I feel like this is the moment that starts Pam's storyline of feeling
very easily replaceable because she's been studying and studying this manual and thinks she's kind of
had this great idea about how to use this new information and it's just like that replaced.
With some tape. At eight minutes and 41 seconds, I want you to know on Pam's desk, Nick is still in the office all day.
Well, the Post-it is still there.
Nick has been in the office for three episodes now.
All day.
Yeah.
Nick in office.
All right.
Now we're going to get into this really wonderful scene in the conference room.
The Angela Kelly rivalry is going strong.
Kelly is talking to Charles about how she has to leave early on Tuesdays to pick up her little sisters from school because, you know, they're kind of like the Kardashians.
Angela's going to come in because she wants to show Charles that brochure for the accounting seminar she was telling him about.
Yeah.
Well, you remember he has.
as a degree in accounting. Charles is like, did Michael just allow anyone in his office at any time?
Okay, so this was in the script. I looked it up to see how much was ad lib and wasn't. And there was a
prompt for Angela and Kelly to talk at the same time. And we did add a little bit more,
but basically we both just were going to gush like, oh yeah, he was like, come on in. I felt like this
was super animated, Angela. Well, you know, she is turning on the charm for Mr. Charles
minor. I know. She said there was a Sunday bar at the accounting seminar, but she didn't eat any,
you know, just a trim. And then Kelly shoes her out and turns to Charles and says, yeah,
she's really special. You know, she's turning 50 this year. I was actually 37 when we filmed this.
I am 50 now. You know, when we were trading messages with Aaron Short, he wrote us about a prank
that Idris Elba played on the writers before he came to set.
Yeah.
Now, he actually said, I don't know if this was a prank that Mindy played on us,
pretending that it was from Idris or if it was actually from Idris.
But I guess they got this email that was like, listen, Idris gets really upset if you mispronounce his name.
And his name is pronounced Idris Ilba.
That's so ridiculous.
And they wrote it out.
Idris Ilba.
Yeah, they sounded it out.
But then a bunch of them were like, I swear that's not right.
And so for the first week that Idris was on the show, all of the writers were afraid to call him by his name.
And then they found out that this was not true at all.
Number one, that his name is Idris.
And number two, that he doesn't get mad if you mispronounce his name.
But I thought that was really funny.
Idris, was that you or was it Mindy?
By the way, Idris, we have.
tried to reach out to you. We don't know how to get a hold of you. We'd love for you to be on the show.
We did find some of your peeps, but they said you're, you're busy. Very busy, I guess. You're
making two movies and you're promoting another movie. You're busy. We're here for you, Idris.
Anytime. If you would like a Scotch and Splenda. Where are your gals? With two gals who
loved to Google. We're here for you. Well, Charles has a talking head where he just kind of owns it.
He's like, look, I know the effect I have on women. That's a meme.
Yeah. It's so funny. Well, Aaron Scherer shared with us, you guys, that that talking head was inspired from a real interaction he had. He said there was an actor he was working with, no names. He wouldn't divulge the name, Big Star, who they were pitching a joke to. And the actor was like, this joke would never work because, I mean, I know the effect I have on women. And Aaron saved that. It went in his brain. And Charles had it in a talking head. I really wish.
We knew the actor, but Aaron, gentleman that he is, did not say.
Maybe if we took him out for a scotch and Splenda, he would tell us.
Immediately after this scene, Kelly is not going to give up, guys.
And in the deleted scenes, there's a little bit of what I want to call a flirty in the break room.
Ooh.
Excuse me.
Hello.
Hey.
Having a nice stay here?
Great.
You must be from Jamba Juice.
What's that?
It's a juice company because you're a smoothie.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
Not about that.
Shut up, shut up, shut up.
So she has this really lame pickup line and then immediately just hates herself and goes in the corner and is like,
How? Why don't I do that?
Well, this leads us into a scene that I will call awkward in the kitchen.
Oh, so awkward.
Michael is still trying to recruit people for his business.
And Andy does that thing, you know, that people do when they're uncomfortable.
They either sing their answer or they do it accent.
I think I'm the accent person.
I sing stuff.
Yeah, when you don't want to like really tip your hand.
Yeah.
So Andy's like, oh, oh, interesting idea.
Like he does some ridiculous accent.
But you would be like, that's a very interesting offer.
Yeah.
I mean, the other day I did it while we were working together.
when we were working on that document.
Oh, yeah.
I was like, this PDF editing is difficult.
And then I was like, are you okay?
Because it sounds like you're about to spiral.
I was like, yeah.
Well, it gets only more cringy because now Dwight comes in.
But Michael does not ask Dwight to join his company,
but it is also clear that Dwight wouldn't say yes anyway.
Yeah, so he's like, I've got the farm and a thing.
And let's put a pin in it.
Yeah, let's definitely put a pin in that.
Yeah. Well, we got a lot of mail about this kitchen scene. A lot of people felt like it was out of character for Dwight to not want to join Michael's paper company. And also, people wondered, why didn't Michael want him to join? And I just didn't know if we wanted to discuss. I have my thoughts. Let me hear them.
Dwight is a survivalist, and he doesn't think Michael's company is going to survive.
So ultimately, even though he loves Michael, he's not going to go somewhere where he won't survive, right?
Yeah.
So I think he's very practical, so he's not going to go with Michael.
But I'm not sure why Michael doesn't want Dwight.
Do you have any thoughts?
You know, that is a really good question.
I definitely see why Dwight would say no.
But why Michael doesn't ask, I'm not quite sure.
Yeah.
Do you guys have theories?
Yeah, send us your theories.
We'll add them to a revisited.
But Michael is going to ask Oscar.
And the way he's going to do that is by putting a note in his sandwich.
A piece of paper that he bites into.
Don't worry, it's sterile.
Just saying sterile doesn't mean it's sterile.
I loved that line.
It's like just saying bankrupt doesn't mean he declared bankruptcy.
Exactly.
Michael gets Oscar to meet him outside.
And Oscar immediately starts offering very practical advice
about how most new businesses don't turn a business.
profit for the first two years. And, you know, can he afford that? Can he afford to make no money for two
years? Right. Well, Michael's like, hey, hey, stop convincing me. You got the job. With all your number
lingo. But ultimately, Oscar's a no. And that means that he has to move on to Stanley, who he's going to
stalk outside the bathroom. Outside? He's inside. I guess outside the stall. I don't know how urinals work,
but I imagine he walked up while he was just peeing
because Stanley's like, I'm urinating.
Michael keeps talking to him.
Stanley's like, no.
Michael has then a very sad talking head
where he's like, you know what?
No one said yes to prom,
but I still had a good time.
Guess what?
What?
Pam fixed the copier.
After four hours, she did it.
She didn't let it beat her.
No, she did not.
She knows everything about this machine.
Phyllis is going to copy a piece of paper.
And Pam is like,
did it work? How is it? And Phyllis is like, fine. Fine. So this whole copier storyline felt very
familiar to me. Having worked many temp jobs, having fixed many copiers in my real life, and it just
felt to me like it was written by someone who also had this personal knowledge. Yeah. So I had to
ask Aaron, have you had experience with copiers? You know, because so much. So,
many of his real-life stories have wound up in our scripts, like running past the speed meter.
Yeah, and this whole copier story has so many details. So as it turns out, yes, yes, he told us that he
temped in a ton of offices when he was a struggling stand-up in New York, and he quickly learned
that if you could unjam the copier, you held the power. Yeah. He actually said, quote,
you were like an office magician, a David Copperfield, opening the cabinet of mysteries.
And only a person who has done the copier thing, I feel like totally gets it.
So I totally get it.
He said that he would actually copy the user manuals and take them home and read them over the week.
That's the part that really got me.
He would like learn everything from the manual.
Aaron, I feel you.
Thank you for writing this runner for Pam.
because I was able to draw on a lot of my real-life experience when it came to performing this copier story.
Well, I don't know. Did Michael leave the faky order form in the copier?
Charles finds it. How does he find it? We don't know. But he's going to get Hank and they're going to escort him out the building.
I am sorry. I am not sure that there is a recurring character that I love more than Hugh Dane as Hank.
I know. I know. When Michael's like,
Hank, come on, escort Charles out. And Hank's like, come on, man. Just come on. He's so good.
So good. Michael really wanted to make a farewell speech. Charles is not going to have that.
And everyone watches him as he leaves. And he's like yelling things from his car, right? He's yelling from the parking lot. And everyone's looking down. And they're like, what's he's saying? We can't hear what he's saying. This is what it's said in the script.
All right.
Michael walks toward his car.
Everybody watches from the conference room above.
Michael stops at his car and looks up at the Dunder Mifflin windows.
And then he yells this.
This is it.
This is goodbye.
Forever.
Ah!
It's such a nice day out here.
Freedom!
I'm already.
I can do it now.
I'm going to go for coffee.
That is what was in the script.
And then it says he screeches his tires and drives off.
the camera follows his car, Michael parks just a short distance around the corner, gets out of his car, sneaks back into the parking lot and into the building.
We get to hear a lot of people's opinions on Michael leaving. My favorite is probably Toby.
Mm-hmm.
He says, Michael is like a movie on a plane. Not great, but something to watch.
And then when the movie's over, you're like, now what?
Yes. BJ wrote that talking head, very funny. And we got a piece of mail about it.
What? Someone wrote in, and I'm so sorry, I did not write down your name, to say that a missed opportunity in this episode was Toby conducting Michael's exit interview.
Oh, wouldn't you have loved to see that? And I mentioned it to Aaron, and Aaron said, oh, but he was escorted out. They like to believe that if Michael hadn't been escorted out, he would have had his exit interview with Toby before he left.
Plus, they had written a pretty great Michael Toby scene where Toby helps him with his right.
resume that didn't make it in.
Yes.
Well, as everyone is having these really funny talking heads, Creed had one that was in the shooting
draft and it didn't make it in and I have to read it to you.
Okay.
Creed says, Old Creedy outlives yet another boss, time to put a marble in the box.
And then Creed pulls out a cigar box out from his desk and puts a marble in it.
There are four marbles in that box.
What?
Is that amazing?
Well, like you said, Angela, Michael is not leaving.
He actually army cralls through the front door, through the office.
He goes over to accounting.
This was a really fun scene for us to shoot.
It was really hard not to laugh.
We played around with how I shut the drawer and I ultimately shut it with my foot.
And it was just like so fun.
Steve really tore up his elbows and his knees, though.
Yeah.
Doing that.
He got like a rug burn.
Yes. And Randy told us that they offered him elbow and knee pads. And Steve was like, it's fine. I'll do it. And he did two takes without the elbow and knee pads. And he totally tore up his elbows and knees. He was so committed. Also, Randy told us, you know, when he throws that highlighter at Jim?
Yeah. That was not a real highlighter. That was a faky highlighter. Oh, so it wouldn't like hurt someone? Yes. Remember when Michael throws the pen at Toby's forehead? And Bill had to make a rubber pen.
Yeah. Phil had to make a rubber highlighter and it cost $850.50. Whoa. Yep.
Michael wants everyone to go with him and he starts to pull at Phyllis's chair. And you see it from the point of view of Charles, right? You see Phyllis kind of like lurching, right? Yeah. To the side. If you watch the bloopers, you guys, and I remember this happening, the first time we did this scene, Steve yanks on Phyllis's chair and she fell right out of it.
Oh, yeah, I remember that. And they didn't stop rolling. You know,
No, Michael just goes, oh my God, Phyllis, are you okay? Are you okay? And Phyllis kind of snorts laughs, and she says, yes, yes. But it's in the bloopers and it's great.
Now, Charles is going to find Michael. Yeah. He comes out of his office and they have this really awkward exchange.
Yeah, like where it's going to get physical. All right, in the deleted scenes, Jenna, Charles finds Michael stealing office supplies in a box and chases him through the kitchen.
Michael drops the box of supplies to, like, throw them off.
You know, maybe Charles will trip over it.
And then he, like, last-ditch effort just grabs the big container of cheeseballs and makes a run for it.
Oh, my gosh.
That's why we're going to have cheese balls later in Michael's paper company.
Because in the deleted scenes, that's what he leaves with is the cheese balls.
I love it.
I know.
I wish it had made it in.
So for me, when Michael's like, who's with me?
Who's coming with me?
This is his Jerry McGuire moment.
Instead of a goldfish, it's a bunch of cheese balls.
That is perfect.
I thought we had to hear Jerry's moment and then Michael's moment.
This moment will be the moment of something real and fun and inspiring in this God-forsaken business,
and we will do it together.
Who's coming with me?
Who's coming with me besides flipper?
Here.
I will go with you.
And now for Michael and Pam's moment.
This is your future.
Hello.
I am your future.
You are older and you are very happy now
because you went with Michael Scott, right?
So everybody, come on down.
Now let's just crawl out of here together, all right?
Come on.
Are you doing your best here?
Are you being the best that you can be?
All right.
Everybody who's going to go with me, I want you to stop your foot.
Oh, no.
What?
I'm going with him.
I mean, come on.
Oh, it was so Jerry McGuire.
By the way, I forgot about the goldfish in Jerry McGuire,
and I'll have you know that when we get to Michael Scott Paper Company,
not only do we have those cheese puffs,
but Michael has a goldfish on his desk.
Come on.
Yep.
Well, fans were very split on this episode.
A lot of people loved this turn of events of Michael starting his paper company and Pam going with him.
But other people really thought that it was selfish of Pam to quit without talking to Jim first.
Well, we talked to Aaron Scher about this, and he said two things.
First of all, he said, in a future episode, spoiler alert, Vickram from the telemarketing firm, is going to join Michael Scott Paper Company.
Yes.
He wrote this talking head for Vickram that got cut, but it explained why Vickram decided to join Michael Scott Paper Company.
And it went like this.
When you put your telemarketing career on the line, you haven't put much on the line.
And Aaron said he felt like that kind of summed up Pam as well.
Right.
That Pam wasn't quitting much of a job at all.
Well, if she could be replaced by some invisible scotch tape,
Yeah, right? Yeah.
There was also a line that Aaron wrote to explain this business of Pam not talking to Jim before making this decision, a little couplet of dialogue that got cut, where Jim said to Pam, shouldn't we have talked about this first?
And Pam said, you blindsided me with a house.
Ooh.
And Jim said, you're right. I'll bring your stuff home.
So he did address it, but it ended up getting.
cut. I think it was the right move to cut it because it seems like, I don't know, a real thing Pam is holding
on to that I don't think she is. No, I don't think so. As soon as Jim showed her the house,
she loved it. She felt cared for and loved. She took it on and I think she's been very happy ever since.
So I'm glad that they didn't pin that as some sort of lingering resentment for Pam.
Yeah. Pam catches up to Michael in the parking lot. She says she's coming along, but she wants to be a salesman,
not a receptionist.
And Jim's kind of surprised by that.
He's like, oh, okay.
Yeah.
And everyone is gathered again up in the conference room, and they're looking down as Pam and Michael walk away.
And as they're walking away, you can see the doubt.
You see this change of them being from triumphant to kind of doubt.
Right.
Well, a lot of people liken this ending to the ending of the graduate.
And spoiler alert to anyone who's never seen.
the graduate, but at the end of the movie, the character of Benjamin, who's played by Dustin Hoffman,
crashes the wedding of his love Elaine, and the two of them are running away from the church.
They're laughing together, and then they jump onto this city bus, and it's always just so
exciting, and they take their seat, and while they're sitting there, their expressions kind of
slowly change.
It's a really famous scene.
It's so good.
Well, in the script, our stage direction for this scene was this.
Jim waves as Michael and Pam walk out together.
We stay on their faces as they transition from fantasy to reality.
So I was not thinking of the graduate when we shot this.
I was thinking of a different scene from the movie The Heartbreak Kid with Charles Groton.
Have you seen it?
I mean, a long time ago.
Well, again, I guess, spoiler alert.
the end of this movie, he's finally married the woman of his dream. Sybil Shepard, he's been chasing
her through the whole movie. He sits down at a couch at their reception. And then you just see
this sort of like malaise wash over his face. And he's like, what now? Because for him,
it's all about the joy of the pursuit. But now he did it. Right. And you can tell he's already
restless. I thought of that movie because I always think that's such a perfect moment of acting.
I mean, he's so good in that movie.
But anyway.
Well, I will tell you that Tom Cruise and Renee Zellwiger in the elevator holding a goldfish also have a moment like that.
Hey!
Because I rewatched the movie last night.
Well, this episode ends with something I absolutely love.
There's a conference room scene.
Charles is telling everyone we've lost some employees.
We're going to have to do some shifting around.
And this is so great.
Everyone's reactions are so good.
He's like, you know what?
Kevin, you're going to be answering phones at reception.
Everyone in the room is like, what?
I know.
I am very much in the foreground of this shot.
That was on purpose because they wanted me to react, obviously.
And then he says he's going to put Stanley, who's doing his crossword, barely awake, in charge of productivity.
Dwight is like, are you kidding me?
Aaron said he pitched that idea of having Charles put Kevin in charge of the phones, which is going to pay off beautifully.
the cold open of next week's episode. But he said it just makes him giggle to think that, like,
Charles's big power move after Michael leaves is putting Kevin in charge of the phones.
Yeah. He's like, I got this place. Yeah, yeah. I know what to do.
Speaking of the next episode, ironically, it did not air for two weeks. Oh, no way.
Yes, there was a break. I just thought that was really funny. People had to really wait.
Two weeks. Yeah, this was a big cliffhanger. Also, this is the last. This is the last.
last episode that Pam was a receptionist ever.
Ever?
She never returns to the receptionist desk.
Let's finish our Scotch and Splenda.
To Pam, our IP receptionist.
I know.
Next up, salesman.
To Pam.
I didn't know that either.
Wow.
When we filmed this episode, I didn't know.
I didn't know that you didn't know at the time.
Yeah.
Well, we didn't know what was going to happen.
We didn't.
Wow.
I should have worn my T-shirt today.
that says I would save the receptionist.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Well, listen, there were a lot of other receptionists that come along, but Pam is always going to be our favorite.
Well, thank you, ladies.
At least here on office, ladies.
Come on.
Thank you so much.
That was two weeks.
Next week is Dream Team.
I can't wait to talk about it.
Please don't bring any scotch and Splenda.
We can't do it.
We can't have a Scotch and Splenda and do that podcast.
You know what I'll bring next week?
A giant pile of friendship.
toast. Oh gosh. Don't bring that either. Listen, thank you so much to Aaron Shore and Randy
Cordray for giving us all the inside details on this episode. We'll see you next week.
Bye, you guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially
created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by
Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our Second Drinks episodes are produced by
Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.